[Aplausos]
[Música]
alemania es un país famoso en el mundo
entero porque es donde se han inventado
todas esas perversiones que no se habían
inventado previamente en japón hablamos
del lugar donde ha nacido rammstein la
cultura nudista y los coches de marca
bmw
[Música]
sin embargo alemania tiene algo aún más
importante que todo eso hablamos de la
auténtica fábrica del mundo tal cual
como lo oís y si ya se lo que estáis
pensando no se supone que es china el
país donde se fabrican las televisiones
los móviles y prácticamente todo lo que
compramos hoy en día pues no es del todo
cierto por supuesto que china es el país
que lidera el ranking de exportaciones
pero también necesitan importar un
montón de productos del extranjero
[Música]
alemania sin embargo vende mucho más de
lo que compra es más uno de cada diez
productos que se venden en el mundo está
hecho en este país que tiene 15 veces
menos población que china por supuesto
todos conocemos las grandes empresas de
automóviles como bmw audi y volkswagen
pero hay muchísimo más
[Música]
todavía no me creéis pues mirad vuestro
teléfono móvil sí ya sé que en la
etiqueta pone ensamblado en la república
popular de china pero si abrís la
carcasa os encontraréis un montón de
microchips verdad pues por ejemplo el
componente que hace que la pantalla rote
cuando movemos el teléfono estará hecho
seguramente por una empresa alemana que
se llama box sensor tech pero no sólo
eso muchos de los robots que utilizan en
las fábricas chinas para ensamblar los
distintos materiales también están
fabricados por trabajadores alemanes
en otras palabras alemania es el lugar
donde se fabrican las cosas que van
dentro de las cosas que fabrican otros y
os preguntaréis cómo es esto posible no
se supone que las fábricas se construyen
en lugares con mano de obra barata cómo
es posible que alemania con unos sueldos
relativamente altos sea una semejante
potencia industrial hoy vamos a
responder a esta pregunta pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
gordo liberalismo tras la segunda guerra
mundial toda europa estaba destruida por
los bombardeos así que países como
italia francia o la alemania occidental
que era la parte de alemania que tenía
un sistema capitalista recibieron una
inyección de millones de dólares por
parte de su amigo el tío sam pero
esperad un momento porque cada uno de
estos países utilizó ese dinero de
formas muy distintas en francia tenían
como presidente a este señor que veis
aquí el general charles de gaulle de
gaulle venía del ejército y no era muy
amigo de las empresas y la competencia
su doctrina política
el llamado dirigismo consistía en
nacionalizar todas las grandes empresas
y dirigir toda la economía del país como
si fuera un ejército en alemania
occidental eligieron un camino
totalmente distinto
tanto el canciller konrad adenauer como
su ministro de finanzas- ludwig erhard
llevaban años teorizando sobre un
sistema económico distinto un sistema
que combinaba la competencia del libre
mercado con la red de seguridad del
estado a este sistema le pusieron un
nombre horrendo lo llamaron orden
liberalismo o economía social de
mercados
[Música]
la competición es el mejor medio para
asegurar la prosperidad ludwig erhard en
otras palabras mientras que de gol
central hizo toda la economía en el
gobierno de parís konrad adenauer diseñó
un sistema donde el estado pone las
condiciones y los demás actores toman
sus propias decisiones
esto explica por qué en alemania son tan
importantes los sindicatos los gobiernos
regionales y por supuesto las empresas y
ahora os preguntaréis cuáles son las
claves de este sistema realmente ha
funcionado ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
y estabilidad monetaria estoy seguro de
que todos habéis escuchado a algún
economista decir que devaluar la moneda
es bueno para mejorar las exportaciones
verdad por ejemplo imaginad que tenemos
una fábrica de zapatos en mexico
y queremos vender un par de zapatos en
eeuu por 2 mil pesos en este momento en
el que hacemos el vídeo estos dos mil
pesos que equivalen a unos 110 dólares
estadounidenses pero imaginad que de
repente el banco central de méjico
decide imprimir e imprimir más billetes
y por tanto de evaluar el peso de un día
para otro ese par de zapatos valdría por
ejemplo 90 dólares es decir
aparentemente sería mucho más fácil de
vender en el extranjero esta es la
teoría que sostiene en casi todos los
gobiernos de hoy en día
sin embargo el gobierno alemán hizo todo
lo contrario durante toda la segunda
mitad del siglo 20 el marco alemán se
convirtió en una de las divisas más
estables del mundo y os preguntaréis
cómo es posible que alemania pudiera
exportar tanto si sus productos no eran
tan baratos pues bien vamos a volver al
ejemplo de los zapatos
he buscado por internet y he encontrado
una empresa en el norte de alemania que
se llama desmán se trata de una pyme con
poco más de 200 trabajadores empezaron
justo después de la guerra en el año
1946 y se especializaron en la
fabricación de máquinas para fabricar
zapatos para eso lógicamente necesitaron
importar un montón de máquinas muchas de
las cuales estaban en eeuu gracias a
tener una moneda estable el precio de
importar estas máquinas era
relativamente barato y hasta pudieron
invertir en alquilar una nave industrial
a fin de cuentas como los alquileres no
iban a subir era muy sencillo calcular
si podían permitirse todos estos gastos
año tras año
[Música]
no sólo eso como las empresas alemanas
no podían competir en precio a desma no
le queda otro remedio que innovar en
1960 invirtieron en el desarrollo de
tecnologías punteras para poder hacer
máquinas que fabricarán suelas de goma
así que diez años más tarde desma se
convirtió en el líder mundial de
fabricación de máquinas que hacen suelas
de pvc muy probablemente la suela de los
zapatos que lleváis ahora mismo esté
fabricada por una máquina de ésta
a que solo tiene 220 trabajadores vende
a todo el mundo incluido china y este es
sólo un ejemplo más de las miles de
pequeñas y medianas empresas las
llamadas mittelstand que han hecho rica
a alemania que me gusta del éxito de las
mittelstand ha atraído miradas de
admiración del resto de europa y sí ya
sé que en el año 2002
los alemanes abandonaron el marco y
empezaron a utilizar el euro pero
pensadlo bien otros países como españa
venían de utilizar monedas mucho más
inestables alemania sin embargo llevaba
décadas de ventaja pero esperad un
momento porque esta no es la única razón
que explica este éxito del modelo alemán
vamos a ver más
el sistema educativo ya sé lo que me
vais a decir con seca alemán ya no es
famosa por su sistema educativo si
miráis por ejemplo el informe pisa
alemán ya no está ni en los diez
primeros puestos sin embargo los
estudiantes alemanes encuentran trabajo
nada más terminan los estudios y os
preguntaréis por qué la respuesta está
en su sistema de formación profesional
imaginad que estudia en un instituto
alemán y no queréis ir a la universidad
así que os metéis a hacer un curso de
formación profesional para ser por
ejemplo electricista pues bien desde el
primer día que hacéis ese curso ya
estáis trabajando para una empresa que
tiene un convenio con el colegio de
lunes a miércoles vais a clase y de
jueves a viernes vais al taller en este
taller os van a formar los propios
trabajadores y la empresa os va a pagar
un pequeño sueldo lógicamente estamos
hablando de poco dinero unos 300 o 500
euros al mes
ojo que esto es muy importante el hecho
de que paguen a los estudiantes
significa que les tienen que sacar
partido porque si no pierden dinero así
que la empresa es la más interesada en
que los alumnos trabajen y aprendan
y creedme sé de lo que estoy hablando
porque yo estudié formación profesional
en españa en españa los estudiantes de
fp van al colegio durante un curso y
medio y solo es en los últimos meses
cuando hacen las prácticas en la empresa
estas empresas tienen prohibido por ley
pagar a los alumnos y que ocurre pues
que no tienen ningún incentivo para
poner a trabajar a los estudiantes así
que yo me pasé tres meses de mi vida en
una oficina sentado en una silla
mientras jugaba a la serpiente con el
teléfono móvil
[Música]
en el caso de alemania es totalmente
distinto durante dos años los
estudiantes han estado en un entorno
profesional real y de hecho muchos de
ellos se quedan en las empresas donde
han hecho las prácticas y por supuesto
las empresas alemanas también ganan unos
trabajadores bien formados pero ya que
hablamos de los trabajadores hay otra
pieza clave en el sistema alemán
los sindicatos alemanes en otros países
como francia casi toda la legislación
laboral se redacta en el parlamento en
alemán ya no es así para que os hagáis
una idea hasta el año 2015 los alemanes
ni siquiera tenían un salario mínimo
estipulado por el estado
todos los sueldos se negocian entre los
sindicatos y las empresas en este país
los sindicatos son importantísimos de
hecho las grandes empresas como audi o
bmw que tienen más de 2.000 trabajadores
están obligadas a tener a los delegados
sindicales en el consejo de
administración al mismo nivel que los
accionistas
por ejemplo una empresa como siemens
tiene a 10 representantes en la junta de
accionistas y por tanto también tiene
que tener a otros 10 representantes de
los trabajadores que ha dados con esto
porque es muy importante en españa por
ejemplo una empresa tan grande como
telefónica no tiene delegados sindicales
en el consejo de administración los
representantes de los trabajadores sólo
pueden participar en un órgano aparte
que se llama el consejo de empresa y
solo pueden negociar sueldos y
condiciones laborales
sin embargo en alemania los sindicatos
están presentes en todas las decisiones
de la empresa si por ejemplo siemens
quisiera abrir una nueva fábrica o sacar
una nueva línea de productos al mercado
tendría que consultarlo con los
accionistas y con los trabajadores y os
preguntaréis esto qué ventajas tiene
para las empresas alemanas normalmente
damos por hecho que los sindicatos y las
empresas son enemigos naturales verdad
pues lo cierto es que no tiene por qué
gracias a esta política laboral los
trabajadores de siemens o bmw o audi
saben en todo momento sin empresa está
ganando o perdiendo dinero y por
supuesto cuando las cosas van mal pueden
negociar una reducción temporal de horas
de trabajo por ejemplo en lugar de hacer
despidos
opel recortará las horas de trabajo en
sus fábricas alemanas es decir que
gracias a los sindicatos y su poder de
negociación las empresas alemanas no
tuvieron que hacer despidos masivos
durante la crisis financiera de 2008
esto es bueno para los trabajadores pero
también es bueno para las empresas que
pueden aguantar mejor las situaciones de
vacas flacas
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque ya sé lo
que estáis pensando que los sindicatos
alemanes están conchabados con los
empresarios para explotar a los
trabajadores verdad pues lo cierto es
que no
de hecho el salario medio en alemán ya
supera los tres mil cuatrocientos
dólares al mes para que os hagáis una
idea
berlín tiene unos precios muy similares
a madrid
[Música]
sin embargo pese a tener unos salarios
tan altos alemania es el tercer país que
más exporta del mundo así que ahora la
pregunta es creéis que vuestro país
podría mejorar si imitar a el modelo
alemán
tal vez pensáis que es imposible
implementar este tipo de políticas en
otros lugares
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
conocer el modelo económico de francia
podéis hacer click en este otro vídeo y
por cierto tengo que darle las gracias a
antonio avis que fue delegado sindical
en cáceres por haberme ayudado a
entender mejor cómo funcionan los
sindicatos en españa y como siempre no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
ah